I was ready to ask her to marry me I
wanted to of course surprise her I had
ordered the ring up I put it in this
very nondescript box just in case
Chrissy was kind of in my backpack
looking at anything I wanted it to look
nondescript not like a ring box we had
to go through airport security and they
decided they wanted to do an extra check
on my bag inside that bag of course was
this ring I was trying to keep a secret
from my future wife and we're going
through the rifling through the bag they
look at the box and they're just about
to open it and at the last second they
decide they're not going to open it I
would have had to propose Chrissy Teigen
at the Colombo Sri Lanka airport
if they would open that box but luckily
they didn't open the box and I proposed
as I planned on the beach
in the Maldives